parler de la bataille des couples alors
c'est le torchon brûle sachez entre nani
et fanny on sait pas qui c'est mais pour
calmer les esprits la psychologue de
l'émission leur a proposé de faire un
jeu assez original se rendent sur un
roof top dans une piscine et crier leur
haine face au monde entier
au début tu trouve ça sympa et très vite
ça commence à bouger sont en place et
j'ai bien quand est-ce qu'on doit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
répondre candidat puisqu'il s'agissait
d'un jeu dans lequel il fallait épeler
des mots
so faire des fautes d'orthographe vous
avez vu comme ils sont vicieux d'amener
guy savoy la brière et on espérait tous
un miracle fait rien par miracle et je
vous le dis j'en mesure de vous le dire
[Rires]
bouille de môme ken hill christophe
s'intégrer comme en paix sociale
et s'inviter au deuxième est-ce que
effet jeu
il être possède ce bravo c'est vraiment
de la merde
nous le savons aussi quand on cherche
une info très pointu qu'est ce qu'on
fait on va sur google
et bien hier dans la bataille des coupes
quand ils ont besoin d'explications
précises il se tourne vers le google de
l'équipe c'est dylan dylan que
j'embrasse puis voilà je il le sait
pourquoi je l'envoie là le problème
c'est que les infos de dylan même sa
femme elle les comprends plus d'ailleurs
c'était son anniversaire à sa meuf
aujourd'hui je crois c'est est
aujourd'hui me dire je vous souhaite un
très bon anniversaire regardons wave on
est gris un peu dommage leur
comportement des soirées qui sont pas du
tout voulu profiter avec les dents nous
on a un peu mais on est un petit peu en
3d quoi bon un peu cul entre deux
chaises c'est à dire qu'on a a fait 6 2
puis 6 6 et l'autre fait celui-ci si
j'arrive à avoir refait genre bah il ya
une fesse de qu ici il ya une chaise 1-1
et chaises et un autre fils de cu sur
chaise
on évalue entre deux chaises mieux vaut
avoir le cul entre deux chaises que de
16 entre eux vécu
juste un gros big up à parce que la
vidéo qu'il a fait là sur la ou flat qui
s'est exprimée la célèbre hexago voilà
bravo moa et lesquin violente un sens
oui on est violent mais bon jusqu'à la
v10 est très grave il a fait rire non
plus exempt fumée bah oui oui mais bon
il devrait temporiser plutôt que 10 des
risées c'est inadmissible ce qui aide
les créateurs qu'ils nous entendent et
qui savent pas peut-être sept cinémas
dit il fallait tirer à balles réelles
voilà sur l'étang les banlieues dans les
banlieues et 7 réagi violemment mais
comme on le connaît
voilà c'est mon ami mais voilà il sombra
soirée et je trouve que voilà et là
c'est inadmissible qu'à l'être alors
tout cas ils montent au créneau
l'eau veulent attendu comme le messie ça
y est c'est fait maeva est revenu dans
les marseillais passaient le journal
évidemment c'est l'euphorie générale
dans la maison tout le monde saute de
joie tout le monde est content il va pas
longtemps si ça
[Musique]
retour à la lia magna puisqu'au face
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
je veux pas que ça tombe bien pour les
rues mais non c'est vrai tout tombera
magdalou
[Musique]
côté les élites adversaires